August might seem like a slow month for movies,
but that doesn't mean there isn't plenty of
entertainment available.
One of the best ways to wind down the summer
is by watching trailers for what's ahead—glimpses
of the horror, romance, action, and drama
that's set to arrive in theaters over the
coming months.
Here are all the August trailers that are
guaranteed to blow you away.
mother!
Written and directed by Darren Aronofsky,
Stars Jennifer Lawrence and Javier Bardem
as a couple whose peaceful existence is disturbed
when guests show up in their home—a simple
premise that, as the trailer suggests, may
not actually be so simple.
The trailer offers a thrilling and terrifying
glimpse at Aronofsky's newest attempt to mess
with our heads, featuring creepy imagery along
with deeper hints at the film's disturbing
plot.
Sign us up for whatever nightmares mother!
has to offer.
The Wilde Wedding
Basically the main you need to know about
The Wilde Wedding is that Patrick Stewart
has hair, but the rest of it looks pretty
good, too.
Stewart plays Harold, a writer preparing to
marry retired film star Eve, played by Glenn
Close.
The guests at their wedding include John Malkovich
as Eve's ex-husband, as well as Minnie Driver,
Grace Van Patten, Orange is the New Black's
Yael Stone, and The Americans' Noah Emmerich.
Killing Gunther
Arnold Schwarzenegger is the most feared hitman
in the business in the upcoming action comedy
Killing Gunther, written and directed by Saturday
Night Live veteran Taran Killam.
Schwarzenegger stars as Gunther, who becomes
the target of an assassination plot from his
fellow hitmen.
Killam's directorial debut seems both stylish
and funny, and Schwarzenegger, while only
appearing briefly in the trailer, looks great
in his role as a ridiculously skilled assassin.
"Go ahead, kill me!"
Mark Felt: The Man Who Brought Down the White
House
Liam Neeson plays Deep Throat in the true
story of Mark Felt, an FBI agent became the
Watergate whistleblower for Washington Post
reporters Bob Woodward and Carl Bernstein.
The talented cast is rounded out by Diane
Lane, Tony Goldwyn, Josh Lucas, and Michael
C. Hall.
Literally, Right Before Aaron
Justin Long stars in Literally, Right Before
Aaron as Adam, a man still reeling from his
recent break-up when his ex-girlfriend calls
him to let him know she's getting married.
Adam agrees to go to the wedding, and predictably,
things quickly take a turn for the worse.
The Florida Project
Sean Baker's Tangerine follow-up The Florida
Project has all the heart and beauty shown
in his earlier work, albeit in a new setting.
This time, Baker investigates the lives of
those living in an extended-stay motel in
Orlando, focusing specifically on a precocious
six-year-old and the motel's owner Bobby,
played by Willem Dafoe.
Dafoe is the grounding force of the trailer,
but the child actors are given the chance
to shine as well.
Already enjoying rave reviews, The Florida
Project looks like a beautiful, touching exploration
of childhood.
Brawl in Cell Block 99
It's Vince Vaughn like you've never seen him
before in the trailer for Brawl in Cell Block
99, the latest action outing from Bone Tomahawk
director S. Craig Zahler.
Vaughn plays Bradley Thomas, a former boxer
who resorts to drug running in an effort to
save his marriage after losing his job as
a mechanic.
Things quickly go wrong when a drug deal turns
deadly, putting him behind bars.
Goodbye Christopher Robin
The new trailer for Goodbye Christopher Robin
stars Domhnall Gleeson as A.A.
Milne, the author who dreamed up Winnie the
Pooh for his young son Christopher Robin.
Margot Robbie takes on the part of Milne's
wife Daphne in the film.
The trailer deals heavily with Milne's struggle
with PTSD, but manages to balance drama, humor,
and heart in a way that will hopefully translate
into an affecting biopic.
Batman vs. Two-Face
Adam West's final performance as Batman is
teased in the trailer for Batman vs. Two-Face.
The Batman legend reprised his role alongside
Burt Ward's Robin, with the two facing off
against Harvey Dent, voiced by William Shatner,
in this sequel to 2016's Batman: Return of
the Caped Crusaders.
Suburbicon
Directed by George Clooney from a script co-written
by the Coen brothers, Suburbicon stars Matt
Damon as Gardner Lodge, a man dealing with
the violent advances of a loan shark in his
small, 1950s-era American town.
Oscar Isaac and Julianne Moore costar, and
with so many huge names attached, it looks
like Suburbicon is a town audiences won't
want to leave—even if the residents most
definitely do.
Last Flag Flying
Break out the tissues before you watch the
trailer for Richard Linklater's Last Flag
Flying.
Steve Carell leads the dramedy as Richard
"Doc" Shepherd, who recruits two of his Vietnam
buddies, played by Bryan Cranston and Laurence
Fishburne, to help him bury his son after
he's killed in Iraq.
The three leads have great chemistry, and
their growing bond helps anchor what looks
like an emotional cross-country journey.
Death Wish
Bruce Willis is out for vigilante justice
in the first trailer for Eli Roth's Death
Wish, a remake of the 1974 film of the same
name.
The movie follows Willis as Paul Kersey, a
doctor who seeks revenge after the violence
in the streets of Chicago spills into his
own home.
While remakes are old hat at this point, Death
Wish looks like it could be worth a trip to
the theater.
Molly's Game
Jessica Chastain stars as the smart, straight-talking
Molly Bloom in the first trailer for Aaron
Sorkin's directorial debut Molly's Game, which
tells the true story of the Olympic-class
skier who ran an exclusive high-stakes poker
game.
As the trailer shows, the movie follows Molly
on her way up in the poker world while also
showing her downfall.
Chastain also has some impressive backup in
the movie, with costars Idris Elba [IH-dris,
not "eye-dris"] and Michael Cera.
Call Me By Your Name
This film festival darling stars Armie Hammer
as Oliver, an American professor who travels
to northern Italy in the summer of 1983.
While there, he falls into a relationship
with a 17-year-old Italian boy.
With an early 100 percent on Rotten Tomatoes,
Call Me By Your Name clearly isn't a movie
you want to miss.
Super Troopers 2
It's been a long, long time coming, but the
first trailer for the upcoming Super Troopers
2 is finally here…and it's awesome.
The sequel to the cult cop comedy features
the group of Vermont state troopers fighting
with Canada over the borderline, setting up
a new Highway Patrol station right in the
conflicted zone.
Considering the fact that the original writers,
directors, and cast are all on board, this
sequel should be well worth the wait.
"Not so funny meow, is it?"
Gemini
Explore the dark side of celebrity in the
trailer for Gemini.
The movie stars Lola Kirke as Jill, an assistant
to a Hollywood starlet named Heather, played
by Zoë Kravitz.
When Heather is murdered, Jill learns she's
a suspect, causing her to reevaluate her own
views of friendship, truth, and fame.
The trailer hints that there could be more
to Heather's murder than meets the eye, raising
a whole bunch of questions to be answered
in the film.
With already stellar reviews from its film
festival premieres, Gemini is a stylish murder
mystery we're looking forward to figuring
out.
The Death of Stalin
Veep creator Armando Iannucci is about to
satirize yet another country's government,
judging by the first trailer for The Death
of Stalin.
The movie shows the mad rush for power after
Stalin's passing, with Jeffrey Tambor, Steve
Buscemi, and Jason Isaacs playing characters
looking to take charge.
"When I said no problem what I meant was:
No.
Problem."
It may not be a Game of Thrones-level fight
for power, but we're definitely on board to
watch this not-so-historical comedy.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!